recording in progress
hi I'm Stuart Creek I'm with simply
learn we are the delivery partner for
Caltech
this is the Caltech Center for
technology and management education
career information session about the
artificial intelligence and machine
learning boot camp
which uh
we deliver from simplyarn and which
contains content from IBM
I'll be telling you about that today
um we'll be talking a little bit about
you through some poll questions
of questions that you would like to ask
put those in the Q and A
in Zoom or into the comments in your
streaming services
let me get this uh go back and start the
LinkedIn live streaming
great got it
again welcome to the career information
session
on the artificial intelligence and
machine learning boot camp
the Caltech Center for technology and
management education
in partnership with IBM and I am Stuart
Creek from Simply learn we are the
delivery partner for Caltech
be asking some questions about you and
if you're on the streaming services you
can answer the poll questions through
your chat or comment box but otherwise
if you're on Zoom you'll see the poll
widget come up
I'll be telling you a little bit about
Ai and ml careers in along with
um Mike Ash who is
one of the directors of Caltech ctme
and we'll talk about what the Caltech
boot camp is the learner outcomes
and we'll go through the enrollment and
steps
so I'm going to let Mike
introduce himself
and
we'll hear from him just a few minutes
the um I spent 25 years in in Consulting
under IBM and Deloitte
uh a press Waterhouse working with
companies uh leveraging Advanced
Technologies
um in IBM several projects around
cognitive Computing how do we exploit
new digital Technologies and and that's
what I do and I work with clients to
make
their new strategic opportunities and in
digital initiatives uh whether that's
for
internal efficiency gains or they're
creating new platforms that they're
going to either sell or compete with
within Caltech we covered several
Industries because of our science and
engineering background
Aerospace energy
Electronics high-tech and what we try to
do in the programs that we have are
bring courses that could either build up
skills or help you develop leadership
skills and and professional skills
and our audiences are typically people
who are technical in in the roles that
they play
so we have this uh this program and
we're pretty excited about it and one of
the reasons we think that it's important
is as we see how companies are really
trying to extend the performance that
they have uh whether investing in new
technologies they're they're coming up
against some some obstacles and some
barriers and the only way is to get past
those especially dealing with all the
data that comes in from digital
platforms is
being able to use advanced math
and machine learning to be able to
um not just manage that data but
interpret what is it telling you what is
it telling about the services that you
offer what does it telling you about the
customers who are using or the users on
a platform and because that it is
growing and becoming more complex we
need Advanced tools just to deal with
this stuff right
um and so some of these machine learning
tools are in the background you don't
really notice them like recommendations
on Netflix
or on Spotify but they're also in places
where we as a research institution love
to do Advanced things and I'll talk
about those in just a second
uh
in a program like what we'll talk about
today which is a really a comprehensive
boot camp
it this is an intermediate program so
really for people who already have some
coding and development skills
but we really want to you're you're
looking to grow into a role where you
can use new skills and those might be as
a software architect or a developer
you're developing tools using machine
learning
uh you're creating new algorithms you're
really improving the uh
products through uh software that either
learns more about the problems that it
has to solve or about the the
environment around it
so
with rigor that this program has we're
really trying to help people grow into
these kinds of roles that that you see
and all of those are in high demand not
just within science and engineering but
within media and Communications and
medicine and consumer products and I
think you guys already know this and
that's why you're here
whatever trying to build new
competencies around Ai and machine
learning uh
Advanced development
you need to have a
lot of different skills this is not just
a field that has one particular skill
and some of these what you're going to
be exposed to are are skills that are
methods and skills that are around
certain software and and the libraries
um
as as a
sorry
um
we're going to give you a background in
more of that and understanding
probability a little bit of linear
algebra
python we're going to be doing a lot of
coding in
over on the far side if you see numpy
numpy is the one of the science and math
libraries for Python
and the that's used extensively in in
the work that we do in Caltech and not
just our group of course the the larger
Institute if you go to the numpy website
there are two case studies that you'll
see on their home page uh one is how
they use the tools within that
particular package to do the Imaging of
the black hole
m87 by Dr Katie Bowman's group Dr Bowman
lives in my building right here uh here
on campus her team
worldwide
worked on the Imaging of m87 I think in
other case study you'll see there is for
ligo which is a gravitational wave
Observatory that was also invented
um
initially theorized intervented here at
Caltech uh by Kip Thorne who got a a
Nobel Prize
um so these are the kinds of tools and
skills that you can use in any kind of
commercial business but also if you're
in science and engineering that really
wanted to break through things
um
then we're going to help you get there
all right so let's get back to our
presentation
so Mike has briefed you on the
roles and skills involved in this field
and we assume you're all here as he said
because you're interested
in joining the career field of
artificial intelligence
machine learning so the question is what
has prevented you up until now from
taking
certification to get into the field
I'm going to leave this open for about
20 seconds you can pick
One Two Three or all four and if you're
on a streaming service you can put A B C
or D for your choices
um
but is it because you can't find a
comprehensive curriculum that covers
everything that Mike talked about is it
because
you don't feel you'd have the Practical
experience after the program to to show
off your new skills is it because
there's a difficulty in
self-study
only programs or is it because you can't
find the time
in your schedule to
do this kind of study so I'm going to
close the poll in three
two
one
and
today's audience the major objection is
not feeling that you would have
practical experience to show off your
new skills
to your employer to a potential future
employer followed by not finding a
program the fully comprehensive
curriculum so
let's move on from there and talk about
the artificial intelligence machine
learning boot camp from Caltech ctme
the six-month program it's about 10 to
15 hours a week time commitment
and it is a comprehensive curriculum as
I'll describe in just a few moments
but it's an industry-aligned learning
path and the reason
that Caltech ctme is able to
align so well with the needs of
Industries because that's
their particular Niche they prepare
people they train people who are working
Professionals in youth skill areas
and
so they understand the needs of
employers come to them for training
assistance
the program is delivered fully online
there are integrated labs and Hands-On
projects that you do in the online
environment same online environment that
you use to attend your live virtual
classes each week where you interact
with your instructor you can ask them
questions
answer their questions go through their
examples live interact with your
classmates
um
during the rest of the week you have the
freedom to access the platform 24x7 so
that you can do your projects and review
your study materials on a schedule that
fits your particular lifestyle and your
needs
um it's all done through your desktop or
laptop a lot of the materials also
accessible on your mobile device so you
really have a lot of flexibility in how
you access the material and how you take
the program
the end of it all you're going to
receive not just the certificate from
Caltech ctme which certifies that you
have
successfully completed the the core
courses and done your um
Capstone project and demonstrated your
Mastery of the skills you'll also
receive certificates along the way from
the IBM courses that are provided as
part of this program
you'll also have access to IBM
hackathons they ask me anything sessions
master classes
master classes from Caltech instructors
um
if you are in a position that requires
you to prove your continuing education
Caltech ctme program offers 22
continuing education units
it's a valuable asset for people in that
situation
um you get to be in the Caltech CTE
circle on an online Alumni Association
and you also get to be recognized that
an online convocation
where Caltech will call your name and
you'll be able to invite your friends
and family to see you at recognized for
your achievement so
all of that's part of the program and
it's all delivered but I simply learned
from Caltech Caltech has been around for
over 130 years it's a private
institution it's not part of the
University of California or California
California State University system
um but it's mainly a research
institution it focuses Less on
undergraduate than on graduate Education
and Research
and it's produced the number of uh Nobel
Prize winners for their research done at
Caltech it's also attracted a number of
people who won Nobel prizes for research
done elsewhere to come to Caltech and
continue that research there are
Caltech Lake the jet propulsion
laboratory of NASA which develops deep
space
spacecraft and probes
and Caltech consistently ranks in top
five universities in the world there's
if you're familiar with the Big Bang
Theory television show you
understand why they chose to sit
um
Caltech is the setting for that program
because Caltech is where you find
a lot of the best and brightest Minds in
the world but having the name of Caltech
on your resume on your CV is a
prestigious accomplishment it's
recognized worldwide
I'm going to ask people if you're asking
questions uh you want me to answer later
put them in the Q a
or in your chat box in your streaming
service let's see if we can get to those
um at the Q a portion
um but the Q a function in Zoom is
better than the chat because I'll be
able to find the questions more easily
there as I mentioned before IBM is a
participant in this program and they
provide access to ask me anything
sessions hackathons master classes
python for data science courses taught
by IBM instructors and it gives you a
Ministry recognized
IBM certificate that is in addition to
your Caltech ctme certificate for the
program so
this is an added bonus for the the
program and added exposure to Industry
leaders and requirements
so this is a fairly straightforward
program to enter you do need to have
some knowledge of mathematics and
programming
some experience with coding or knowledge
of it
some experience of mathematics or
knowledge of it
um
education requirement is just a high
school diploma
the 18 years of age
and
it is preferred that you have two or
more years of work experience formal
work experience in any setting not
necessarily in programming or AI or in
those fields but
always helpful to have the work
experience that lets you understand how
organizations work how they use data and
where these types of Technologies can be
applied so
with that in mind I'm going to ask
another question which is how much
experience do members of our audience
today have
will give you about 20 seconds to answer
this question
please get your answers in
again if you're on the streaming service
A B C or D will help
and I'll close the poll in about five
more seconds
three two
or
so today's audience is uh
heavily weighted towards more experience
we have
almost two-thirds of our audience who
have more than five years of experience
a few of you are still in school working
on presumably working on your bachelor's
degrees but uh
this sounds like the audience today is
well qualified for this program it's
great
so moving forward
let's talk about how the program
prepares you
so this program is designed to build
your skills and Ai and machine learning
step-by-step basis
core set of courses
that must take in order to complete the
program and win your certificate
or earn your certificate I should say
it's not a contest uh you start off with
an orientation or induction session
where you get a
introduced to the online learning
environment how to use the controls what
your curriculum will be the class
schedule the expectations what
preparation you should be prepared to do
for each
live class sessions which of the courses
are done with live classes and which are
done through self-study
and you move into the introduction to
artificial intelligence
covering the basic concepts
then a practical
course in Python learning how to use the
Python language in data science
follow-up course to that is applied data
science with python and using more hands
on examples to develop your skills
then moving to machine learning and
understanding how
AI models can teach themselves as they
obtain more data about the real world
and refine themselves it's a machine
learning process then you move into deep
learning with tools like Keras and
tensorflow
and advanced Steve learning and Machine
Vision
looking deeper into applications of
these Technologies in Practical examples
of how they can interact with the Wheel
World
the final module of the mandator hearing
modules is the Capstone project three to
four week project
uh you meet weekly with your instructor
you choose a problem
based on a real world type of problem
that you would encounter in industry and
you develop Your solution to that
drawing on all of the skills and tools
that you've learned about in the
previous uh
five months of the program
results in a project
that is graded for your uh final
Award of the certificate but it's also
something that you can take with you in
your portfolio on a permanent basis and
show to employers
as proof that you have not only learned
these skills but you know how to apply
them
use them in Practical examples
along the way you could take uh the
electives there at no additional charge
they're based on whether you have the
interest and want to commit the time to
taking them they include statistics
Essentials for data science natural
language programming and speech
recognition reinforcement learning the
master classes from Caltech extractors
as well as
ask me anything sessions and other
sessions from IBM
so along the way you are going to
be required to use a number of different
tools platforms
in the projects that you do it's not
just a matter of you will be exposed to
these and learn their names and
what they do but you will be required to
use them in your coursework
and once you finish the program you'll
be able to point to these tools say
these are now part of my permanent skill
set so python different uh python
libraries
other tools for uh
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
and all of that gets drawn into the
Capstone project and you pick up a
project Challenge from one of several
and you take that on it takes three to
four weeks to develop your Capstone
project
you'll meet weekly with your instructor
who will make sure that you don't fall
into any rabbit holes or dead ends
and at the end of the process you have
something for your permanent portfolio
show off to employers as practical
experience with AI and ml
I'm going to share with you this clip
about
the learning platform so
gives you an example of how the learning
platform works
welcome to Simply learn and our unique
online boot camp where millions of
professionals have gotten the skills
they need to succeed there are two
components that make our online boot
camp approach so successful great
content from the world's leading
technology companies practitioners and
universities and a unique and
proprietary learning environment that
was specifically designed for high
engagement and learner support when you
log into simply learn you set the course
timeline that meets your busy work and
home schedule and keep track of your
progress every step of the way we'll
help you stay on plan with automated and
24 7 human support at the core of our
programs are our live virtual classrooms
where you interact Real Time with
trainers that are recognized leaders in
their field there you'll review key
Concepts get questions answered and
interact with your peers the important
reports on the audience if you notice
are demographics this is super useful
especially if you're running
you could do it on social media later
you'll learn social media marketing too
by looking at these numbers you will be
able to understand the age range of
people that you should be targeting you
know what you could just focus only on
that age category
advertisements to them very useful
that's not all you get to learn from
faculty at Global universities and
Industry experts via master classes at
ask your questions to top industry
leaders in exclusive ask me anything
sessions so other interesting question
on the chat box and say that oh to
optimize in YouTube you could use the
rising session of Google Trends and
optimize it okay so let's go back to
here right here where it says web
searches and you can see that there's
going to be the YouTube searches okay so
now you can see that the YouTube
searches is going to be so there's a
option uh under not just web search and
there's going to be a YouTube search
okay so just go ahead and click on
YouTube search and you should be able to
optimize your search
so what do you think
any sort of
sort of video
apps would appear within those video
contents so you would be caught when you
are watching an original video and leave
you a video app and then go back to the
original video content
we believe people learn best by doing go
beyond practice
tackle practical problems with multiple
projects and simulations and work on a
real world Capstone project that you can
showcase to Future employers your
learning isn't restricted to just live
classes explore our highly effective
self-learning videos and other resources
to fine-tune your learning and remain up
to date always you can focus on
different learning approaches by subject
to personalize the overall learning
experience to your learning style and
needs at the end of it all you get to
walk away with globally recognized
certificates from top universities for
the program leading companies for
specialized courses and simply learn so
come on in experience professional
learning like you've never done before
get started today
and so you've seen uh to recap how you
manage your curriculum through the uh
virtual environment you see all the
classes that comprise your program uh
and what sequence they're going to come
up in it schedules you through them so
that uh each time you complete one you
unlock access to the next one you get
calendaring so that you can see what
your classes live class schedules are
you get reminders and prompts to keep on
track be able to do your tests
assessments the labs projects all of
them on that same platform
and the Capstone project included
along the way as you complete each
course you unlock a certificate for it
and then when you finish the entire
program you unlock the master
certificate for the program from caltex
ctme you have support tools that allow
you to interact with your peers
um allow you to ask questions on a
community Forum allow you to ask
questions of faculty
um
24x7 support for the platform itself as
well as 24x7 support for the subject
matter so if you're working on a
project at three o'clock in the morning
and you reach some point where you're at
a dead end you'll be able to reach out
to somebody and get some help so this is
a great
platform and
very proud that Caltech chose us as
their delivery partner for it
um
now Mike's boss is Rick Hefner and Rick
has over 40 years of experience in
industry and Academia
um so he oversees the entire Caltech CTE
program and specifically overseas
the curriculum with this boot camp
but this is as I said a Caltech ctme
program delivered by simply learn
talk about some learner outcomes
and where people come from people come
into this program from certainly from
Information Technology and software but
also from
many other Industries uh Ai and machine
learning apply now across the board to
almost every industry
and as we're seeing with things like
chat GPT it's coming
a more
um General tool accessible to everyone
or all sorts of different types of of
work so it's not just a
software or information technology
field anymore it's a
general purpose tool for all aspects of
Industry so you have people coming in
from
manufacturing from Pharma Health Care
from Financial Services
consumer goods
the
you'll be rubbing elbows with people
coming in from many different
backgrounds
program
a number of different uh
students who've said things about the
program about how well it's worked for
them
and how easily they've been able to
learn with it
and I'm sure that the end of this
process you'll have similar stories to
tell
and one of the reasons we're confident
of that is because we offer a career
assist Services part of the program
this extends for six months after you
earn your
certificate
so along the way and for six months
afterward you have access to
educational sessions that we run weekly
uh free webinars on Zoom
an expert uh topics on Career skills and
other aspects of job search
so these are all available to help you
with your career on an ongoing basis
there's no limit on those
um
the real world projects and the Capstone
project that you do during the program
become your portfolio which is also an
important job tool
and then the six months of job assist
services that extend after the
um
certificate
include access to the resume rabbit job
portal from Talent Inc
which gives you access exclusive jobs
through their Network on a confidential
and discrete basis
then we think the other two parts of
this program are
um even more valuable one is the resume
review and rewrite service because
today your resume will go into an
automated tracking system before it goes
before any human being so an AI bot
we'll look at your resume and evaluate
it against job descriptions and you need
to have your resume formatted in a way
that the AI bot can recognize what's in
it
and match it up correctly to the job
descriptions that's kind of an art form
in itself and then recognizing that once
it passes that filter the resume will go
in front of a human being on their
screen or desktop means that you have to
balance that
uh goal with the AI bot compatibility
goal so
that really makes it an art form and
working with a professional writer who
can help you with that is very valuable
service
um the one-on-one interview prep is
equally valuable because you'll go
through many uh different types of
interviews
your next job search you'll go through
phone screens with HR you'll go through
uh skill screens and Skillets interviews
to test your knowledge of your of AI and
machine learning and then you'll go
through compatibility interviews that
look at your cultural fit and ability to
be a team player and to be to have
one-on-one interview prep for each of
those types of interviews it's really a
valuable part of this program so
again this is not a job guarantee
program but it does give you a lot of
assistance with your job search
I mentioned the expert webinars you'll
have
ability to access webinars about
overviews of the industry specific uh
technical topics mini lessons and a
particular skill
how to
conduct a job search or how to plan out
your your career and
the necessary
career and soft skills for that and all
of this is free and available to you um
a lifelong learning basis
and we talk about
being able to choose
um
applications or problems for your
Capstone project and other projects that
you do in the program
choose from things like social media
challenges or an ed tech company
challenge or Healthcare challenge
or Manufacturing these are the kinds of
program projects
choose to work on
and build up
material for your portfolio
so our next cohort the classes start
March 18th
and we have an induction session coming
right up
the cost of the program is nine thousand
nine hundred ninety nine dollars
it can be financed on a zero interest
basis at 880 a month
and I mentioned uh or if I forgot to I
should have mentioned oops sorry a bonus
for attending today's program so if
there's any today's webinar
if you enroll you'll get a 500 discount
off of those fees
locking it down to nine four nine nine
and so
want to reach out to us and ask us at
simplylearn.net
for that
opportunity
and I'm going to ask
interest question to see
based on what you have heard so far
are you interested
and enrolling in this program
while you're doing that I am going to
put the email address into the chat for
you
going into the chat
now
and I'll close the poll
and just under three quarters of our
audience are interested so I'm going to
share with you
share the results here
I'll share with you
the steps you need to take in order to
do that and I've put into the chat
the email address and the URL for our
web page
so
you'd go to ask us at simplywin.net
email us there
and the lending Consultants will ask you
a few questions to verify your
educational background which is pretty
straightforward high school diploma
and to assess your work experience
and then to provide you an assessment
test about your background and knowledge
of programming and Mathematics just a
simple
test that will verify that you have the
requisite aptitude and interest
to succeed in this program
and once you've passed that review
you'll get an offer of admission
will you'll be able to join the next
induction session and get ready for
classes
and so
that being said
those of you who said you were
interested how soon would you like to
start something you'd like to start with
this set of March classes coming up
maybe April May or further out
we always say that if this is something
that is going to change your life and
your career for the better
wow I guess we'll do it sooner than
later
I'll leave this open for five more
seconds
two one go
so uh almost two-thirds of our audience
want to begin either in March or in
April or May
just fantastic if you're looking to do
this more than six months out or six
months you know more than three months
out
do contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net what we'll do is we'll
answer any
linear and questions you might have and
um
keep you informed about future cohorts
of the program
at this point I'm going to
pick your questions from the Q a and if
you put them in the chat please um
to transfer them into the Q a because
it's very difficult for me to
sort through the chat a lot of
a lot of comments there
um
Cheryl asks finding an affordable
program is also a factor stopping some
would you agree I absolutely agree this
is a
sizable commitment of
finances
um a commitment of time if
you have to be the one to decide if this
is something for you that is worth
um
what you'll gain on the other end in
terms of being qualified for a new
career in Ai and ml so
um
well
freely admit that
uh Syria I think I hope I hope I covered
uh simply when Caltech and IBM balance
IBM teaches some of the courses they
provide amas and
a master sessions
um Caltech instructors however Master
sessions
and they um
supervise the
industry expert instructors that
actually conduct the courses
are the Capstone projects individual or
team projects Charlotte the Capstone
projects are individual projects
um there's a team element in terms of
meeting weekly with your class to go
over uh questions and that type of thing
but you do the work on your Capstone
project individually so it's something
that goes into your portfolio that you
can then explain
show off to potential employers
uh how long will online material be
available including live classes
so some of the online material is
available indefinitely those are the
video and self-study
programs
recordings of your live classes that
you've taken in the program I believe
you have six months to access those
after you
complete your certificate again if you
you need to achieve a certain number of
live classes you need to attend a
certain number of live classes and in
each course description when it talks
about what you pass the course it'll
tell you how many live classes you have
to attend
um but if you miss a live class and you
need to review the material
um each live session is recorded So that
you can go back again you need to attend
a certain number of them live
do have access to the recordings for
review or to catch up on anything might
have missed do you get access to or job
assets you get access to caltech's job
portal uh not specifically you get
access to the job portal through Talent
Inc
um but of course
you will be able to apply to any Caltech
listed job just like anyone else
and you
will be able to cite on that that you
took the training from Caltech ctme so
um
how is this program different from the
master's program
so yeah that's a good question
one of the main differences is the
involvement of Caltech the Caltech uh
master classes in Caltech supervision of
the of the curriculum so
differently from our master
program our master's course
this one allows you to say that you took
the training from Caltech ctme
oh it's a
qualitatively different program
what happens uh
honor what happens if I cannot spend 10
to 15 hours in some weeks you do have
the ability to catch up but you want to
make sure that you're able to kind of
keep up with the program the 10 to 15
hours includes things like watching
video uh content to prepare for the
class
es themselves happen on weekends so for
the live classes you would spend four
hours Saturday four hours Sunday from 8
to noon the mornings and um
again if you have to miss a class you
can catch up on it from the recording
but
generally speaking you can do the rest
of the work on any schedule you know any
hours that you find throughout your
weeks
but do you have the ability to catch up
you do have the prompts from the system
that will keep track of where you are
and what you need to catch up on so
can a mechatronics engineer get a job in
machine learning uh Andrea I
that's a great question and the answer
to that is is yes because
machine learning if you look at
something like Boston Dynamics and their
robot programs
all of that is based on machine learning
um
the ability of their different
robot platforms
to balance on two four or two legs deal
with external forces like being pushed
or shoved or catching something
um
they've refined all of that through
ongoing process of machine learning
where the
software running the robot has
encountered different real world
challenges and
adjusted itself adjusted its models to
deal with that so mechatronics is a rich
field for
machine learning
um
Cheryl asks
what sets Caltech program apart from
other boot camps other AOL programs
mention chat GPT so as our curriculum
gets refreshed frequently chat GPT is
going to be part of the
especially as part of the module on
neural
language programming and um
natural language program I should say
and
speech so yes that will be part of that
part of the program which happens being
elected in this program but um the thing
that sets this program apart from others
more than anything else is the Caltech
associations
a veterans discount
um
Edison please
contact us at ask us at simplylearn.net
and ask that question of the learning
counselors
they'll be able to help you with that
um
so he'll
does not really have experience in
programming but has mathematical
analytical experience
you have scoped to pursue this course
what I would say to you sahil is if you
have the mathematical and analytical
background
um
that is it's better to have that and not
the programming and then the other way
around because what will happen is
you can take uh programming courses
including the
python for data science you'll be
exposed to the programming Concepts and
if you want to Preparatory work from the
time you know between the time of the
induction session and the start of the
first classes you can take some of the
free courses on the simply learn website
that will give you some basic exposure
to programming Concepts um so that is
easy to pick up and and then after that
initial exposure
what you need for this program will be
in the program itself
why Caltech other Ivy League schools
also provide similar certification
courses they
um and
you know if you look at
as Mike mentioned in his remarks you
look at where
data science machine learning
um
artificial intelligence are being
applied
there's a few places where that work is
being done in an extremely high level
Caltech being one of them so you would
want to look at
other offerings from other institutions
are interested in that but
um
you'll find that Caltech measures up
especially in terms of
access to the institution itself
what kind of opportunities do you think
I would be able to opt for considering I
don't have a software background I'm a
civil engineer so heal so
suppose you wanted to stay in civil
engineering and use machine learning
um
you would be looking at applications for
modeling things like stresses on
structures
um
lifespan of
big
Civic projects like a for example a
hydroelectric Dam or that type of thing
and you'd be able to then see how this
technology applies in your field so the
domain knowledge that you have combined
with the new skills
would give you an advantage in that
direction if you want to switch
directions if you want to go into a
different domain your background in
engineering gives you a
a discipline that will serve you well
when looking at other opportunities to
apply Ai and ml skills
if you switch domains you may have to go
to a more
entry level position to start with but
you should be able to progress rapidly
based on your experience
and how much technical experience Hava
asks which technical experience do I
need I work in sales currently I don't
have a technical degree
only taken front-end development courses
if you've taken front-end development
courses you have the requisite software
exposure
um
and you'll you'll be able to pick up in
the program
exposure to statistics and the
mathematical Concepts that underlie data
science and
machine learning artificial intelligence
model intelligence modeling and that
type of thing
um
so
do not have to have technical experience
if you have work experience
that is valuable in that you'll
understand where in organizations these
types of Technologies and skills can be
applied so this is one of the reasons
why we recommend having least a couple
of years of experience
so
those are the questions we have in the Q
a until now and we're reaching kind of
toward the end of our
our
so let me go on to the end of our
presentation
with one last question
oops
and this is do you need assistance with
enrollment if you would like to receive
a
proof of attendance for tonight's
session for today's session I'm sorry
um
please let me know by answering yes here
otherwise if you need enrollment
assistance and would like us to reach
out to you for help we will
do that if you answer yes here so
launch this question we'll just leave
this open for about 20 seconds
fairly straightforward
and again if you want a proof of
attendance just answer yes here
and I will end the poll now
it's about 50 50. so again uh if you've
answered yes we will be reaching out to
you and we'll send you a proof of
attendance for the session
uh at this point
I want to thank all of you for being
here today uh either on zoom on YouTube
live or on
LinkedIn live
um and on behalf of Caltech ctme and
simply learn I want to invite you all
to join us in the Caltech ctme learning
community
reach out to us at ask us
simplylearn.net or use the QR code to go
to the
program webpage and with that
we conclude our webinars thank you again
we hope to see you soon